was kommt auf die krankenhäuser in
deutschland zu wenn die korona
infizierten und krankenzahlen weiter so
ansteigen wie sie es ja immer noch tun
das ist die große frage die aber vor
allem auch pflegerinnen und pfleger
beschäftigt die warnen schon seit wochen
das ist alles ziemlich eng wird uns
erreichen immer wieder meldungen und
nachrichten und auch direktnachrichten
das schutzmasken das atemmasken das
schutzkleidung fehlt dass sie teilweise
stundenlang getragen werden müssen das
klingt alles relativ gut
deswegen wollten wir heute eure fragen
an eine krankenpflegerin
krankenschwester sagt wenn man früher
stellen das ist yvonne faller die ist
krankenschwester
sie ist pflege dozentin und sie hat den
kers lemm organisiert also eine art
poetry slam für die pflege schon vor
längerer zeit hallo frau aigner in
berlin
hallo schönen guten abend mal ganz
persönlich gefragt wie geht es ihnen
denn zurzeit mit der situation die sie
auf uns zurollen sehen
das ist ein auf und ab also das ist ganz
anstrengen teilweise da wir selbst auch
noch eine versorgung haben für eine
patientin die wir gut absichern müssen
dann kommen natürlich andere gedanken in
den kopf dass man sich denkt mensch
vielleicht wird alles gut vielleicht
lernen wir jetzt auch noch mal etwas das
das gesundheitssystem besser aufgebaut
wird also das ganz durchwachsen sehr
viele gefühle die momentan wirken was
macht ihnen denn ganz konkret sorge
können sie dann beispiel nennen wo es
letzten mal gedacht haben wenn das so
weitergeht dann ist aber hier gute nacht
marie es sind zwei dinge also in
deutschland macht mir sorge der
materialmangel dass wir wirklich zu
wenig schutz material haben masken
kleidung und wenn ich nach italien schau
dann frage ich mich ob wir das auch hier
so bekommen und bin auch wirklich sehr
traurig für die kolleginnen in italien
die da wirklich kämpfen und versuchen
die menschen zu retten und ich finde das
ganz schrecklich dass uns diese pandemie
jetzt wirklich ja so erwischt und wie er
eigentlich gar nicht gut damit umgehen
können weil wir überhaupt kaum
erfahrungswerte haben wir werden uns
gleich noch mal einen ton von einer
krankenpflegerin aus italien an
aber vorher haben wir mal jemanden in
deutschland gefragt die mann der im
krankenhaus arbeitet weil die
krankenhäuser sind ja eh schon eine
belastungsgrenze die ganze zeit wie er
die situation jetzt gerade ganz konkret
erlebt ich habe euch auch selbst müssen
überstunden eingeholt die kollegen sind
einfach noch billig und sagen aktuelle
lage helfen zusammengekommen rein
natürlich ist da sofort eine grenze auch
mit erreicht und kollegen waren schon an
eine grenze der belastung die nicht
gespart werden darf
frau fragt sie sind ja als dozentin mit
vielen krankenpflegerinnen und pfleger
in kontakt was ist so das bild was ihnen
geschildert wird auch sehr
unterschiedlich also einige sind sehr
ängstlich
da halt schutz materialien fehlen sind
wirklich überfordert und am anschlag
sagen wir können das gar nicht schaffen
wir wissen gar nicht wie wir momentan
die versorgung absichern sollen
andere wiederum die fühlen sich noch
relativ sicher da ist einiges noch im
fluss also sehr sehr verschieden
uns erreichen aber auch also mich zum
beispiel persönlich erreichen auch
nachrichten nach dem motto also bei uns
noch alles entspannt gucken wir zu sehr
auf die negativen seiten gerade ja das
sollte man auch im kopf haben
vielleicht sollte man da fragen wo es
halt gut läuft was sie anders machen
aber ich glaube auch dass die kollegen
und kolleginnen nicht lügen die sagen
bei uns ist es gerade so angespannt und
wir haben wirklich kein material mehr
also ich denke man sollte sich
austauschen und zusammenhalten momentan
wir schauen mal hier in die kommentare
eine frage hat uns auf youtube von turck
erreicht wie gehen sie mit dem risiko um
selber infiziert zu werden
ja das ist natürlich die die
schwierigkeiten wir versuchen uns im
team halt zu schützen das heißt wir
fahren eh nur von unserer versorgung
nach hause momentan wir haben ja nur
eine patientin die halt schwer schwer
krank ist ansonsten ist es halt so also
ich meide halt momentan wirklich
menschen also wir haben ja jetzt
einerseits diese sperre dass wir nicht
miteinander laufen sollen und so aber
ich merke dass ich manchmal auch ich war
neulich beim arzt und wollte ein rezept
abgeben und wusste kaum richten wir die
hände halten soll
um dieses rezept abzugeben also der
ganze körper die körpersprache ändert
sich auch momentan finde ich also sind
ganz verrückte sachen also ich versuche
halt mich an die regeln zu halten die
ausgesprochen wurden noch eine andere
frage auch über youtube haben
krankenpfleger gerade überhaupt noch
zeit für familie und freizeit also die
die notbetreuung die tun ja auch den
rest na also
diese die frauen und männer die sind
wirklich am anschlag
die sind froh wenn sie halt auch noch
ihre kinder versorgt bekommen dann kommt
häufig auch noch die angst um die eltern
hinzu dinge jetzt auch mit den
enkelkindern oft keinen kontakt haben
dürfen wie sie die betreut bekommen wie
essen zum beispiel organisiert wird und
momentan ist es so dass die pflegekräfte
wirklich viele viele überstunden fahren
um die situation zu bewältigen
mich hat auf instagram auf meinem
persönlichen instagram kanal eine
nachricht erreicht die wollte ich ihnen
ganz gern mal vorlesen weil die konnte
ich fast gar nicht glauben
hier schreibt jemand die missstände sind
unaufhaltbaren krankenhaus jeder hat
angst keine hilfe unter kollegen in
adäquate schutzausrüstung und dann noch
kollegen die mich ermahnt haben dass es
bestimmt ärger gibt wenn es rauskommt
dass ich über die situation berichte
auch wenn ich es allgemein halte ich
verliebe in quarantäne als drei stunden
in nicht ausreichender schutzausrüstung
zu versuchen einen patienten zu retten
ist dass der drastische einzelfall oder
hören sie solche geschichten öfter ich
habe es häufiger gehört ich muss ehrlich
zugeben ich habe es häufiger gehört ich
habe gehört dass
masken zugeteilt werden eine pro schicht
und dass die kollegen und kolleginnen
halt sich auch nicht einig sind ob man
das nach außen kommunizieren sollte oder
ob man das für sich behalten sollte um
halt auch nicht so panik zu schüren und
ich bin mir da auch nicht so sicher ob
es so gut ist dass für sich zu behalten
kurz der mine eine pro schicht das
klingt jetzt für mich erst mal okay wie
oft sollte es eigentlich sein
ja das ist so dass man schon wenn man
zum beispiel mit einer einfachen maß
gearbeitet sobald die durchfeuchtet ist
also praktisch diese aero sohle
da musste gewechselt werden da braucht
man schon 345 wenn wenn man jetzt so
permanent halten eine maske trägt und
wenn man jetzt mit betroffenen in
berührung kommt da sind die regeln ja
noch mal ganz anders und viel strenger
viele haben ja angst vor zuständen wie
in italien wir haben da mal wenn wir auf
meinen rechner schalten haben gibt es
einen beitrag der ist zehn tage zwar
schon alt aber wir fanden den o-ton
darin sehr stark und deswegen wollten
wir den noch mal vorspielen der ist von
einer kollegin von ihnen von der
intensivstation
und ich hoffe wir hören dass jetzt auch
die sagt dort folgendes
kein ton wir können es nicht hören sie
haben ja nichts ich versuchen wir mal
das hier zu machen
das bringt nichts also ich sage nochmal
kurz wie sie es wie sie es quasi jetzt
wenn wir uns doppelt
also was sie quasi sagt ist wir sind das
nicht gewohnt dass die menschen quasi
bekommen in so einer großen anzahl und
masse die dann quasi nicht mehr zu
retten sind die für uns quasi unter den
händen weg sterben
er ist das eine situation die sie
wirklich auch für uns befürchten weil
ich meine wir sind ja doch ganz anders
aufgestellt als italien wir haben nicht
so viele alte menschen
wir haben mehr intensivbetten es wird
aufgestockt wir sind gewarnt
ist das nicht tatsächlich ein bisschen
panikmache das weiß ich nicht weil ich
habe keine pandemie erfahrung ja also
das ist das erste mal sich dazu sagen
muss andererseits weiß ich dass wir
einen sehr sehr großen pflegenotstand
haben dann haben wir zwar betten aber
keine pflegekräfte die die menschen die
in den wetten sind versorgen und damit
ist das dann halt auch wieder eine eine
milchmädchenrechnung es geht dann halt
nicht auf na also
wir brauchen wirklich definitiv
pflegefachkräfte die an diesen betten
stehen und diese menschen versorgen
können wenn sie kommen wie viel dürfen
sie wenig wie viele pflegefachkräfte
kümmern sich dann normalerweise um
wieviel intensivpatienten
naja 123 sagt man aber das ist ja auch
häufig das 124 also eine pflegekraft
vier patienten und in so einer krise wie
in italien ich glaube da werden alle
miteinander versorgt da findet
eigentlich gar keine richtige versorgung
mehr statt sondern man versucht einfach
nur noch das gröbste zu schaffen und zu
schauen dass man die menschen durch
bekommt die man durch bekommt und das
wäre katastrophal wenn wir das erleben
würden
matti müller fragt uns hier oder sie
gibt es für die angestellten möglichkeit
in den krankenhäusern zu übernachten in
quarantäne zu gehen wenn eine corona
infektion befürchtet oder nachgewiesen
wird insbesondere im hinblick auf den
schutz der eigenen familie wäre sondern
möglichkeit für ganz angenehm
naja ich weiß nicht ob es so angenehm
ist im krankenhaus zu schlafen also wer
das schon mal gemacht hat der weiß wie
es ist außerdem muss man auch daran
denken die menschen haben ja kinder auch
oftmals und es gibt ja auch menschen die
alleinerziehend sind und wie soll das
dann gehen diese ganzen
versorgungslücken die überall
aufgerissen werden also das ist ganz
schwierig ich weiß dass es ein heim ich
glaube in süddeutschland gibt wo
momentan die pflegerinnen mit drin leben
weil es halt auf der seite der
pflegerinnen und auch auf der seite der
bewohnerinnen halt infekt infektion gibt
es noch allerhand spannende frage die
auch viele menschen umtreibt gerade mit
der vergleich mit dieser grippewelle vor
zwei jahren fragten films ist habe ich
völlig bei der schlechtes vorbild in die
hand gekostet da muss ich dir ja wo ja
das ist ein automatismus den muss man
sich abgewöhnen
ja das sage ich ja alles wird anders mit
den händen ja das ist echt schwierig
also froh films fragt uns oder sie ich
frag mich wie unser gesundheitssystem
andere schwere krankheiten überstanden
hat obwohl wir eines der besten haben es
ist wohl nicht genug
nur wenn man bei einer schweren grippe
werde 2017 2018 von 25.000 toten spricht
frage ich mich wie das damals geklappt
hat wie ging das dann müssen doch auch
mehr patienten im krankenhaus gewesen
sein
ok jetzt ist die frage wie verläuft die
grippe also so wie corona also ich kenne
ja jetzt noch kein verlauf von kona aber
so wie es halt beschrieben wird
diese menschen relativ schnell ins
lungen versagen und das ist halt eine
akut intensiv pflichtige erkrankung und
wenn davon jetzt viele menschen auf
einmal kommen dann ist das natürlich
etwas was die intensivstation maximal
belastet das heißt also eingriffe
verlauf kann man eigentlich gar nicht
mit corona verlauf weil ich so nicht so
ganz würde ich sagen dass das nicht
möglich ist weil halt die heftigkeit des
versagens und auch wie sich die
lungenentzündung zeigt
ganz anders ist als was man sonst kennt
hier ist eine frage auch auf youtube wie
können wir kurz mal zeigen von luxus
reden das pflegepersonal sich ansteckt
wo nehmen sie dann das personal her
ja das ist eine gute frage das ist eine
gute frage wie würden sie wahrscheinlich
einfach weiterreichen an dem
gesundheitswesen
ja also ich würde sagen der
gesundheitsminister sollte dafür sorge
tragen dass ja die menschen die sich
momentan im flex it befinden also das
sind pflegekräfte die aus dem beruf
ausgestiegen sind vor corona da sind
viele bei die sind rausgegangen weil sie
einfach die belastung nicht mehr
ausgehalten haben bei vor corona war das
pflegesystem in deutschland schon am
limit und ich würde gern sparen
empfehlen dass er diese fachkräfte
versucht wieder zurückzugewinnen und das
geht natürlich nur über geld anreize das
wird ja schon probiert da können wir das
nochmal drüber sprechen über die
gesundheitspolitik und ihre kritik daran
aber und jetzt in der derzeitigen lage
gibt es tatsächlich viele pflegekräfte
die sagen okay ich packe jetzt wieder an
weil ich bin ausgestiegen aber ich
möchte zurück kommen und da gibt es
tatsächlich auch eine eigene plattform
wo man sich melden kann die wollten wir
ihnen mal vorstellen
dorin teilen hat viel zu tun in diesen
tagen in ihrem kleinen stoffgeschäft bei
düsseldorf sie mit mundschutz
individuell gestaltet und waschbar
eigentlich ist sie gelernte
krankenschwester hat auf der
intensivstation gearbeitet
zehn jahre ist das her doch mit zwei
kindern geht das nicht mehr
jetzt bietet sie sich an dort wo gerade
besonders viel bedarf ist intensiv bett
kann ich heutzutage auch noch irgendwie
betreuen ich habe mich ist ja nicht so
dass ich dann halt von überhaupt keine
ahnung habe und dass man das ja auch
nicht und wie verlernt man hat ja
irgendwann mal gehört und auch mal
gesehen und hat er auch daran gearbeitet
und dann als es keinen mehr gibt oder
halt irgendwie ein ausfall ist dann
steht man ja wieder davor und sagt okay
dann kann ich halt auch helfen
sie hat sich bei care rockets
registriert das unternehmen von patrick
schulz sucht und vermittelt pflegekräfte
außer dienst die sonnen reaktiviert
werden so lange bis die korona krise
überwunden ist und wie man es halt
gefragt was können wirklich machen um
der gesellschaft einen mehrwert zu
schaffen
da muss halt gefragt ob die ausbildung
dauert zu lange eck wiese aus dem
ausland dauert zu lange wie können wir
derzeit den pool von leute mobilisieren
die das ganze können aber der branche
ihm den rücken gekehrt haben
die resonanz war riesig offenbar hat er
einen nerv getroffen inzwischen dürfte
sich herumgesprochen haben dass das
personal in den krankenhäusern am
anschlag arbeitet und händeringend hilfe
braucht denn die pandemie steht gerade
erst am anfang
wir haben ja in deutschland an großen
pflegemangel auch auf der
intensivstation und hier bietet neben
pflegekraft die einem anderen job sind
die aber hierüber care rocket ja
zurückkommen würden alternative an die
wir sehr gern in anspruch nehmen können
nele pfeiffer hat schon erste
erfahrungen gesammelt sie ist
ausgebildete kinderkrankenpflege rinnen
und studiert medizin in polen jetzt will
die 23-jährige in deutschland helfen ich
bin ja auch genau der fachrichtung drin
und kann das ja auch nutzen dieses
wissen und gerade jetzt in so einer
situation dann geschah es nicht solche
erfahrungen zu sammeln für die zukunft
zum beispiel auch für den arztberuf oder
also schon am ersten april fängt sie in
einer düsseldorfer klinik an 20 stunden
die woche erstmal bis juli orient ein
wartet noch wahrscheinlich nicht so
lange in zeiten in denen die
krankenhäuser jede helfende hand
gebrauchen können
tja also der pflegenotstand ist da und
wird sichtbar in den corona zeiten
darüber sprechen wir heute mit yvonne
frank mal in berlin
krankenschwester pflege dozentin und
ganz tief drin in der materie
wenn sie das hören frau aufhalten da
gibt ihnen das nicht hoffnung dass wir
das doch irgendwie schaffen und doch
genug leute da sind die helfen können
na ja die frage ist wie lange bleiben
die leute und bleiben sie kontinuierlich
und stabil
dann muss man ja auch noch überlegen wie
viele werden vielleicht selbst krank
also die müssen ja nicht corona bekommen
also praktisch sich mit corona
infizieren
sondern es kann ja auch sein dass viele
pflegekräfte sagen ich bin jetzt so
erschöpft dass ich nicht mehr kann also
ich dass die frage ist wie wie ist diese
rotation also ist es wirklich stabil
ich glaube wir sollten pflegekräfte für
länger wieder einladen bei uns mit uns
arbeiten zu wollen
wie kann sie das kann nur über geld
erreicht werden tatsächlich machen sie
ja also ich denke einerseits wirklichen
geld anreiz und also für die krise jetzt
also jetzt schon in der krise diesem
geld anreiz setzen und andererseits aber
auch zu sagen hinterher müssen wir
dieses system neu justieren und das dann
auch wirklich mit der basis gesprochen
wird was ist eigentlich wichtig und dass
der stellenschlüssel angepasst wird also
dass wir nicht mehr so viele patienten
versorgen müssen weil wir sind
eigentlich schlusslicht in europa wir
versorgen pro pflegekraft 13 patienten
ist der statistische mittelwert und da
ist halt statistische mittelwert ist
geht es halt auch hoch auf 20 also wir
sind definitiv sehr sehr überlastet in
den versorgungen wir haben ja auch
wirklich schwerst kranke und alte
menschen die einen hohen bedarf haben
jetzt gibt's ja widerspruch auf youtube
von einem nw ich finde krankenpfleger
verdienen sehr gut wenn nach tarif
einstiegsgehalt von freunden in der
branche liegt bei zirka 3000 euro das
ding ist dass nicht alle nach tarif
bezahlt werden und das ist das problem
ist das so richtig erst mal muss man
sagen also die tarife die
tarifentwicklung das sind immer so
kleine schritte
da wird halt immer ein bisschen
geklettert und ich glaube um halt
überhaupt den meridianen mal zu
erreichen der in deutschland typisch ist
sollte man jetzt halt wirklich diesen
beruf aufwerten und das wären dann schon
bei 4000 euro brutto einstiegsgehalt das
wäre eigentlich gut und damit kann man
beginnen
jetzt schreibt ihr wie sie vor
schwieriger name mit viel los hört sich
gut an finden bestimmt auch viele leute
toll wenn das jetzt passiert aber wenn
dann für alle die krankenkassenbeiträge
steigen wenn es die begeisterung vorbei
ja man muss sich halt überlegen wie
wollen wir pflege finanzieren das sind
vielleicht dinge die nach der krise
wirklich kommuniziert werden müssen weil
wir werden uns lange jetzt mit corona
beschäftigen das ist ja nicht in drei
vier wochen vorüber weil wir haben ja
jetzt schon ein schaden dadurch und das
sind halt einerseits schritte ziele und
dann halt auch länger strittige ziele
und ich denke darauf muss sich die
gesellschaft einlassen wenn wir mal in
das praktische gucken was natürlich auch
viele menschen interessiert wenn sie
jetzt in die krankenhäuser gehen weil es
gibt ja nicht nur leute die in die
krankenhäuser gehen müssen weil sie
corona infiziert sind sondern
ganz normalen betrieb auch die ganze
zeit da gibt es eine frage von daniel
julian bosse auf facebook was ist mit
geburten in krankenhäusern in der auch
kuren ab in denen auch koma patienten
behandelt werden und das werden dann die
meisten wahrscheinlich sein
gibt es dafür besondere konzepte ich
habe neulich mal also ich bin ja keine
hebamme
das wäre vielleicht gut wenn hier eine
hebamme sitzen würde aber ich habe einen
kleinen film gesehen dass viele
kreißsäle die regel haben dass die väter
halt nicht mehr bei der geburt seien
dabei sein dürfen und dass die frauen
alleine in den kreißsaal gehen und dass
das halt für viele frauen auch mit angst
belastet ist aber ich habe einfach
wirklich keine erfahrung jetzt vom
kreißsaal wie das geregelt ist es müsste
an eine andere person gerichtet werden
die frage ob aber tatsächlich ist die
frage die man sich stellen kann ich noch
ins krankenhaus gehen man muss sich
wirklich warten bis sich kurz vorm
exitus bin weil man entweder angst hat
das system zu überlasten oder sorge hat
sich zu infizieren ich meine wir haben
ja auch schwierigkeiten mit
krankenhauskeimen noch obendrauf
ja das ist ja gerade dieser balance sagt
natürlich soll der mensch der sich krank
fühlt ins krankenhaus ging natürlich
jetzt nicht beim schnupfen aber wäre
wenn man merkt ich ich ich brauche jetzt
ein arzt ich muss ins krankenhaus
dann soll man das natürlich machen
dürfen es wird ja alles daran gesetzt
das halt die menschen die halt noch in
der regelversorgung sind also wir haben
ja weiterhin den herzinfarkt den
autounfall dass die versorgt werden
können deswegen machen wir jetzt auch
diese anstrengungen dass wir halt
versuchen das nicht so viele corona
fälle auf einmal in die krankenhäuser
einlaufen und das system nicht zu
überlasten
die haben ja eine frage von einer
hochrisikopatienten sarah shell ist die
sagen so die würde gerne wissen wie
beatmete patienten sediert werden ist da
überhaupt noch raum und zeit um auf eine
patientin notfallkarte zu achten und zum
beispiel auf unverträglichkeiten
rücksicht zu nehmen gerade wenn man
allergien hat gegen bestimmte
[Musik]
medikamente oder gegen bestimmte
regierungs medikamente das ist eine sehr
gute frage
die würde ich auch nochmal an einen
anderen fachmann weiter berichten
aber ich kann dazu sagen dass
grundsätzlich man eigentlich dazu auch
verpflichtet ist darauf zu schauen und
das jetzt ein bekannter arzt dazu
aufgerufen hat dass wir grundsätzlich
jetzt alle noch mal unsere
patientenverfügungen durchlesen sollten
um die auch abzuändern
das heißt da auch nochmal vorsorge
treffen tatsächlich genau genau genau
die krise hat aber noch ganz andere
auswirkungen mit denen man vielleicht
gar nicht gerechnet weil natürlich auch
leute betroffen sind davon die damit gar
nichts zu tun haben und da haben wir
nochmal einen o ton aus dem interview
mit dem krankenpfleger andré tietze ich
noch ganz aktuell berichten dass wir
patienten haben die ihnen alternativen
gebe ich alles nicht befüllt und dass
man da auch angehörige über telefon im
film gehen muss wie es den betroffenen
geht man nicht irgend besuch zu lassen
kann wenn man das auch sich selbst um
münst wenn man denkt jetzt verwandten
hätte ihn zum beispiel eher lebensweise
sind und sich recht verabschieden müssen
von jemanden und dann aber nicht ins
krankenhaus köln und sich nicht
verabschieden werden und die beschränken
entsprechend auferlegt ist was man schon
mit nach hause nimmt und eine lange
nacht gehört ja das betrifft natürlich
die patienten oder die hinterbliebenen
aber auch in die pflegekräfte wie kann
man den pflegekräfte auch solche
situationen vorbereiten
ja ich denke wir müssen lernen
miteinander zu sprechen also wir müssen
orte haben wo wir halt auch mit unseren
gefühlen hin gehen können und ansonsten
denke ich das so kritische situation die
brauchen auch ein stückweit krisen
begleitung und das konnte man ja auch
mit anderen berufsgruppen gestalten da
gibt es ja schon ideen psychologen auch
menschen die sehr geeignet sind sind
trauerbegleiter und trauerbegleiterinnen
die haben auch sehr viel erfahrung
gerade wenn so eine menge an menschen
die eventuell versterben auf uns jetzt
drücken dann macht das ja auch etwas und
da sind die sehr sehr erfahren gibt es
denn das schon also so eine art
supervision oder oder menschen wo man
sich hinwenden kann gerade im
intensivbereich für pflegerinnen und
pfleger vereinzelt vereinzelt also ich
duze ja auch und ich sitze hier häufiger
diese themen halt begleitung in
kritischen phasen wo es halt auch um
trauer geht und es ist es hat sich noch
nicht durchgesetzt es ist scheinbar noch
nicht so richtig spruchreif dass es
wichtig ist dass wir die menschen die
halt wirklich grenzbereich leben tod
arbeiten dass wir die gut begleiten dass
sie halt auch ein raum haben wo sie sich
regenerieren können wo man ihnen sagen
kann es ist in ordnung das so diese
gefühle jetzt hast ich glaube wir müssen
da eine ganz andere kultur auch noch
einmal lernen wenn wir jetzt mal auf
diese große gesundheitspolitik thema
gucken das ist ja schon ein schwieriges
feld sehr komplex teilweise da stellen
wir fest dass hat sich lange wenig getan
jetzt tut sich auf einmal doch etwas
konkret sollen die häuser etwa 50.000
euro für jedes zusätzliche
intensivbetten mit
beratungsmöglichkeiten bekommen für
jedes freigeräumte bett auf einer
station will der bund mit tagespauschale
von 560 euro überweisen das heißt da
fließt jetzt geld und es gibt noch
zuwendungen für ein gesetz das material
das kann dann ja auch alles wieder an
die pflegepersonen weitergegeben werden
und da das ganze attraktiver gemacht
werden reicht ihnen das nicht ich denke
dass grundsätzlich momentan ein zeichen
von der politik kommen muss dass man
einfach mal sagt wir müssen jetzt die
tarifpartner momentan beiseite lassen
und wir bestimmen dass also das denke
ich dass das passieren muss weil wir man
muss sich ja auch fragen
ob es nicht manchmal wichtiger ist
größere sprünge zu machen um die zukunft
auch wieder zu gestalten und wir hatten
vor corona schon massiv mit
pflegenotstands zu tun und jetzt geht
das halt weiter und ich glaube dass das
wichtiger ist mutter bahr
gesundheitsminister spahn hat letztes
jahr schon angekündigt dass er mehr
machen möchte es gibt da diesen dieses
pflegepaket er möchte 30.000 neue
stellen irgendwie schaffen und generell
mehr unterstützen das heißt die das
bewusstsein ist ja da zumindest in der
bonner erschafft stellen aber setzt
nicht wirklich den anreiz dass die
menschen kommen das ist halt die
situation die schwierig ist also wenn
ich stellen schaffe ich kann auch ganz
viele stellen schaffen wenn ich aber
keinen anreiz setzt dass es besser wird
also zum beispiel der personalschlüssel
wie auch die gehälter dann habe ich ein
problem dann kann ich ja dann habe ich
unsichtbare stellen die ich nicht
besetzen kann
es gibt jetzt aber auch viel empathie
und applaus für ihren berufsstand und
für ärzte und für alle die helfen das
gibt dieses ritual haben es am fenster
zu klatschen mittlerweile europaweit
bestärkt sie das nicht in der hoffnung
dass das dass das signal angekommen ist
das wichtig sind das wort systemrelevant
finde ich mittlerweile schon ein
bisschen schwierig aber das ist sie
gesehen werden
natürlich es ist gut dass pflege
wahrgenommen wird dass die arbeit von
den menschen wahrgenommen wird die dinge
am laufen halten also wo wir wenig
hinschauen was wir als
selbstverständlich annehmen außer wir
rutschen eine krise das ist gut das
andere ist ein applaus ist auch schnell
vorbei
wichtig ist ob dieser applaus
bewusstseins wechsel auslöst und die
menschen sich noch mal mit pflege
beschäftigen wollen und sich auch noch
mal fragen wollen wie pflege sensibel
möchte diese gesellschaft eigentlich
werden
oder möchte sie halt nur in krisen
befeuern oder möchte sie längerfristig
sagen nein
wir möchten diese gesellschaft so
schützen und dazu gehört ein
abgesichertes gutes pflegesystem zu
diesem ganzen komplex gesundheitspolitik
geht es jetzt hier bei euch keine fragen
aber es gibt
eine bemerkung von jemandem der anonym
bleibt da steht schade dass die pfleger
dann ihren unmut an die patienten
weitergeben ist das auch was man
passieren kam tatsächlich wenn menschen
so belastet sind
ja das ist natürlich vereinzelt gibt es
gewalt in der pflege ja das gibt es
das muss man nicht leugnen das hat aber
auch teilweise strukturelle gründe also
strukturelle gründe bedeuten
zum beispiel wie viel arbeitslast lastet
jetzt auf einen menschen also über
überforderung löst leider aggression aus
und wenn jemand das nicht mehr gut
regulieren kann kann es zu gewalt kommen
dass es keine entschuldigung
das gibt es gibt natürlich auch
persönliche gründe dass jemand
vielleicht selber innerlich sehr
angespannt ist in der lebenskrise
deswegen sich nicht mehr regulieren kann
das muss man alles anschauen in der
regel ist es so dass pflegekräfte er
nicht zu gewalt neigen sondern dass die
größere gefahr in familien ist da gibt
es studien darüber dass zum beispiel
pflegende angehörige die in
überforderungssituation sind häufiger
ihren angehörigen gewalt antun
jetzt gibt es hier zu ihrer forderung
mehr lohn ein bisschen widerspruch in
den kommentaren also user human rights
first schreibt was ändert mehr lohnen an
der erschöpfung wäre das geld nicht für
mehr personal hilfreich hat damit das
personal erst mal besser entlastet wird
das sind ja zwei dinge die er anspricht
natürlich entlastet mehr geld also mehr
lohn ja und wenn man gleichzeitig dann
halt noch mal
sagt wir müssen jetzt längerfristig auch
wirklich uns überlegen wie wollen wir
pflegen welchen personalschlüssel wollen
wir begleiten das sind zwei dinge und
man muss beides machen geht in eine
ähnliche richtung user oder userin nun
user schreibt lohn ist ja schön und gut
aber was nützt ein guter lohn bei
bleibenden inhumanen arbeitsbedingungen
die krankmacher nicht weiß jetzt nicht
ganz genau worauf er angespielt wird
haben sie eine idee was damit gemeint
sein könnte es ist er beides ist es
einerseits diese dieser dieser druck
diese hohe arbeitsbelastung die wir
haben und andererseits halt auch dass
wir sehr sehr viele patienten zu
versorgen haben und dann kommt halt auch
noch eine schlechte entlohnung hinzu das
sind ja auch dinge die sich gegenseitig
beeinflussen
und wenn man erst mal anfängt halt auch
praktisch eine wertschätzung über geld
wieder auszudrücken und gleichzeitig
eine gesellschaftliche diskussion anregt
wie wollen wir jetzt so weiter pflegen
wie sollen die stellenschlüssel sein
dann haben wir eigentlich schon gewonnen
also ich denke das wird ganz ganz tiefe
fragen zu beantworten haben twitter-user
der alte hase hat einen vorschlag und
schreibt würde rente ab 55 10 job
attraktiver machen um mehr personal im
beruf zu halten
im moment sind die 55 jährigen besonders
attraktiv sie werden gerufen dass sie
soll zurückkommen quasi ja also das ist
die frage also die frage ist wie können
wir neue pflegekräfte gewinnen aus also
auszubildende die auch bleiben weil wir
haben eine hohe abbruch also eine hohe
quote an ausbildungsabbrüchen die liegen
ungefähr bei 30 bis 40 prozent
dann haben wir nur kurze verweildauer im
beruf dh die menschen bleiben maximal
sieben bis zehn jahre im beruf das heißt
wir haben einen beruf ja nicht
nachhaltig aufgestellt ist und das sind
halt die fragen die wir wirklich
beantworten müssen wie können wir dann
eine tiefere nachhaltigkeit kommen
sie haben ja eine petition mit
unterschrieben die gerade von pflegenden
befeuert wird und kursiert wo ganz klare
forderungen drin sind können sie mal
ganz kurz knapp zusammenfassen was da
ihre wünsche sind oder forderungen an
die politik
also die erste forderung war das schutz
material sich also praktisch
bereitgestellt wird und notfalls das
produzierende firmen erstmals
staatsauftrag bekommen dass sie halt für
die krise schutzkleidung zu produzieren
haben
das ist eine forderung so ganz einfach
erklärt das ist eigentlich umgesetzt
worden weil jens spahn kümmert sich
jetzt darum dass schutz materialien ins
land kommen die andere forderung ist das
erst mal diese ganzen qualitätsprüfungen
die zum beispiel der altenpflege wichtig
sind dass die ausgesetzt werden solange
die krise ist weil so lange wir jetzt
praktisch im ausnahmezustand arbeiten
und auch kaum schutz material haben
können wir auch nicht die qualität
nachweisen die wir eigentlich nachweisen
müssten und die dritte forderung die
auch praktisch umgesetzt wurde also jens
spahn hat sich also drei forderungen
vielleicht zum herzen genommen ist dass
die mitarbeiter des mdk es jetzt md also
des medizinischen dienst der
krankenkassen das sind da sind die
prüfer und prüferinnen häufig krank also
fachkräfte dass die halt zurück in die
direkte pflege kommen dh da bewegt sich
was genau dabei können sie ihn uns oder
auch den krankenpflegerinnen und
pflegern in deutschland mut machen oder
hoffnung machen dass tatsächlich wird
durch diese krise vielleicht durchkommen
und dann doch sich etwas zum besseren
wendet also wenn wir jetzt nicht so sehr
nach der krise fokussieren sondern schon
in der krise die diskussion anfangen und
halt auch in der krise damit anfangen
diesem beruf besser wieder aufzustellen
werden wir sicherlich eine größere
chance haben es zu schaffen
grundsätzlich glaube ich also dass
pflegekräfte menschen sind die auch
wirklich der gesellschaft etwas
wiedergeben möchten die haben sich für
einen beruf entschieden
[Musik]
sie wissen dass sie eine hohe
verantwortung haben
ich glaube dass man das schaffen kann
aber die diskussion die muss halt
weitergehen und wir können das nicht auf
nach der krise so verlagern weil wann
ist denn die krise zu ende da gibt es ja
auch widersprüche
die antworten der eine virologe sagt wir
brauchen anderthalb jahre ein anderer
wiederum sagt das wird lange lange
gesellschaftlich sich niederschlagen
wurde wo wir dann halt arbeitsaufgaben
haben und ich denke dass wir jetzt in
dieser krise dass wir diese krise als
chance nehmen sollten zu sagen wir
müssen jetzt alles auf den tisch packen
die diskussion haben wir heute abend
versucht ein stückchen weiter zu treiben
vielen dank frau fekter für ihre zweite
vielen dank für eure fragen und
kommentare jetzt im stream ich hoffe wir
haben die meisten beantworten können und
wünschen euch jetzt erstmal ein
einigermaßen entspanntes wochenende und
wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder bis
dahin sage ich mach's gut und tschüss
und welches team gefallen hat dann guckt
doch vielleicht mal hier rein die haben
wir gesprochen mit der psychologin
annette wolf über die frage wie man die
isolation vielleicht besser durchhält
oder in dieser sprechstunde hier haben
wir einen biologen über das corona virus
gesprochen außerdem gibt es hier die
ganze playlisten durchführen und
natürlich lasst uns ein abo und leicht
an
[Musik]